so the first of our lightning talks
chris we're giving fur going first of
course we all know the rules of this
game you keep to five minutes uh and
then at a certain point we start getting
increasingly more rude to get the person
off stage but chris i'm sure you'll keep
time
and this looks wonderful please give us
a warm welcome to chris
hi everybody my name is chris lafra i'm
with jp morgan we were the original
sponsor of num focus we created
non-focus and well we didn't create it
we just gave some money
and uh
i was at the first pi data so it's i've
been to a couple in in the history of
different locations uh new york but also
estonia which was a memorable one for me
and this one is even better i brought a
snake like the one that the keynote
speakers have
get
so i'm going to give this one to the to
the best or do the one lightning talk
that i like the most and not my own
because i don't want to bring it home
so uh whoever gives a lightning talk
right now uh you have a chance to win
this one
so why why are we doing this talk
everybody deals with complexity in large
python applications
so what i will show you is a way to see
inside the application
and then what you can do with it this is
how it actually works
so we instrument certain functions so i
detect them and then i use monkey
patching to replace them with
extra logic that draws things in the
browser
and with that you get custom
explanations and you understand what is
happening so this is actually athena so
this is the project i work on njp morgan
and this is an application that says
book a deal so this is actually
this is jp morgan this is like what we
do we book deals so this is a market we
make money this way
so when you run this let me run f5
so i have a repl here as well that runs
python3
very modern
and when i say f5 i'm not that five this
five
here
function f5
fighting with my keyboard
uh it's currently running so this
program will run for a while it it's the
first time i run it so it has to include
some modules and those dependencies so
eventually you will see in the picture
that we load around like 5000 modules
these are all the modules that we need
to actually calculate a trade
so the first one is very expensive but
then the next ones will be faster of
course
so what this program does we have
instrumented some of the code and i saw
you some some python rules there
findman rules
and they send commands now to the
browser and it's rendering here in
javascript so you can see the execution
while it's going wrong so i'll
scroll around a bit
and the whole idea here is here that
we can actually start exploring what the
program is doing so at the top you see
the number of modules that has been
loaded so it's like 2.6 000 now
and it's going up you can see there's a
delay it's sunday because the connection
to the server actually didn't really
work so well you can see how long it
takes
so let's zoom out a bit you can see
a big black space in the middle that's
where no cpu happened
so we're already learning some things
here of the behavior
i can zoom in on this part here
you also see number appear so anybody
has used number in the past
you can see how expensive it actually is
to compile things so i can zoom in here
and see
that it takes like 2.4 2.5 about seven
seconds to
compile about like maybe 12 functions
here so which one did we compile so i
can click on it
and it takes me back to the source code
so i can see
here
which code it actually is so that
function is now jitted
but the irony is that in my scenario i'm
next not ever using this one right
so now i found uh something that i can
optimize in my application i can say
like okay let's get rid of these number
things and i can start solving a
performance problem
um so this is like very low level but it
allows you to yeah navigate
from the low level execution i try to
level up like gives you better
abstractions so you can understand
what's going on
and the goal is to be
use this in training scenarios where
people want to learn what a scene is all
about but also for improving
optimization and reducing you know time
spent in aws and things like that
so project feinman is available
on github.lafra
and once you're there you can also check
out my own page chrislaffer.com i wrote
a book communication engineers
you should all read it get a copy
and thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you chris showing you how it's
done 40 seconds to spare that's what we
like to see
right
uh sham i think you're next with uh data
science for tax love your stuff so you
want to get yourself set up data science
for tax
now my understanding about taxes it's
deterministic
you will find out more but i like the
idea
of paying a variable amount of dax
does it
here we go that's on there
there we are
right okay you ready to go yep lovely
big camera applause
actually can't see anybody
um
i didn't really expect to give a talk
today on this conference until yesterday
i realized when i talk to people about
what i do most people are giving me this
blank face like tags very much like what
emily's saying and then walk away so i
thought okay i will talk to you a bit
more uh in this kind of setting
a bit about myself uh i just joined the
delivery as their tax technology lead
so because i'm so new this doesn't
represent anything deliveroo does yet as
is from my previous experience i was
trained as an economics and
economication
and then i joined the big consulting
firms and qualified as tax advisors and
accountants afterwards after 54 exams
and after that i decided data analysis
is much more interesting so i
specialized in the international tax
area where it has economics most related
topics there
and give you a tax prequel it doesn't
even count as tax 101 just so that the
reason i joined tax because i firmly
believe taxation is useful for uh
funding public infrastruct
infrastructure
and redistribution of wealth
broadly we have four types of taxes but
there are quite a lot more depending on
the countries direct tax with tax on
companies
a company's profit and indirect tax you
tax in
transactions that's when you get your
when you pay for whatever you see vat in
a lot of countries you will see that
international tax where i specialize in
deals with cross-border transactions
predominantly personal attacks i believe
you all see that on your pay slip when
you have one
um
in terms of data science what we do a
lot of times uh
nlp there's a lot of nlp um work around
your invoices correspondence tax
authority emails and that kind of thing
we do a lot of clustering and looking at
insights from your from your data so one
thing we found in one of the projects is
um in india the word cement leads to a
lot of non-deductibility in tax for some
reason there's a tax reasons behind it
if you you're interested in
and binary classifications will have a
lot of classification issues in tax uh
often they're like deductible or
non-deductible
expenses for predictions or multi-class
classifications you might think your tax
has like 20 rate that's done for the day
but actually in a lot of countries like
italy has 36 tax codes or
turkey has like over 100 tax codes so
all of that are multi-class
classification issues based on invoice
descriptions and multiple data sources
we also have computer visions a lot of
you might not know we have like scanning
invoices to actually go into our source
data before it goes goes into erp
systems
and inferential statistics and deep
reinforcement learning other things
more to do with tax policies i don't
actually personally use it on the deep
reinforcement learning part if you're
really academic you're interested in you
can look at the ai economist from
salesforce and but influential
statistics one thing if you have heard
recent years we have like the digital
tax on companies like delivery or google
facebook that's coming from a
talks like i in my phd studies i did
looking at the relationship between
intangible investments and effective tax
rates and i did find some statistic
significance on the correlations between
those two um but that that actually
driven a lot of tax policies as well
challenges in tax um one of the things
that top tip if you really want to know
what data goes around in your company
join tax data science because that's
where you get all the data requirements
it's all over the place it's not just in
finance systems erp systems it's in your
work day in your people system as well
and then
data quality issues i have a lot of
imbalanced data because it goes with the
business as well so you might have like
products that you don't actually use
very much
and scalability is a net merit in tax
because each country has different tax
legislations just because they all
called vat or direct tax doesn't mean
that the rules follow the same so often
i did one countries when it goes to the
different countries you have to revise
your models straight away completely and
finally governance we didn't really have
that much much fun
of like saying if you did it wrong for
sentiment analysis it's not big deal but
if you get your tax wrong even to the
penny you might get penalties later on
there's a lot of consequence after that
oh fun time just in case you weren't
persuaded by my wonderful talk about tax
and you didn't like it
i recently discovered this website
called boxes.pi it's open source box
generated in python you can make a
flexbox like this um it's a useless box
that they will close it up
so oh it's done by someone called florin
festy i should really give you um uh
give his quick credits
if you want to link up with me and
deliver is hiring in their data science
team um
i get bonus for every firm
thank you thank you very much
shannon that is talk worthy we've got
gotta have that at the meetup that
sounds great
so many issues with tax fantastic
right who have i got next i have
infants triage with baby bear so that
would be habib
habib are you here there we go off he
comes habib is uh one of my colleagues
and um here we go fun stories fun
stories with the beep yes one of our
american colleagues um pronounced
habib's name um habibi
and remind remind me habib what does
habibi mean in nigerian uh it's an
arabic name habibi means my love
and that's why it's important to
pronounce people's names properly
right
yes
okay you all ready
yes would you like to watch some netflix
yes this can save his netherlands
how does that help with procrastination
at work
yeah i'm going to just display this
screen here quickly uh duplicates does
this mean you can import netflix
this gets us into very difficult waters
when it comes to
why i have to say it is important to
note that netflix is in no way
associated with the pi data brand yes
keep changes okay
yes
there we go
cool fantastic all right habib you have
five minutes okay warm welcome
[Applause]
uh
thanks everyone my name is habib
shakbaju um
i'm a software engineer at uh premade ai
um doing machine learning stuff i
basically just want to talk about a cool
idea that
the applied research team came up with
very recently nothing complicated
so you get to do lots of stuff with
natural language processing and language
models and since language models are
quite huge
in order to process your data you need
to like pass it through those models and
they take time they take lots of
computes
when you get to deploy models that
require
that serve lots of impute from various
customers you can imagine that that
could scale up pretty quickly because
now it takes time to provide your outfit
to one user and then this applies to
multiple users as well
so
uh
basically that just shows what the pros
of using a large neural network is
better results increase confidence in
your results you're able to handle
imputes with larger variation and more
complexity as well but the cons
they are slower to train and
perform inference on
they require larger resources and they
are costly as deploy so what's the idea
the idea here simply is you have two
models where one is a very light model
that can easily
influence stuff starts using lots of
compute and taking a large amount of
time
when you provide the input to your two
models it goes first into your smaller
model where a smaller model should be
able to provide the results and the
confidence so if the confidence is
beyond a certain threshold
you just stick with those results and
decide that the outputs but if it is
smaller than that threshold you then
pass it to the larger model so the
simple idea here is you can easily stick
with passing your your inputs directly
to the smaller model without using lots
of compute on the larger model and
reducing the um
the
the uh
threshold reducing the pressure and um
and uh
what's the word again it is in the
pressure and demand yes demand on your
larger model
basically from the research paper
released by the applied research team
from primary related tasks so it's
covered that could actually reduce
your compute by one third
and this
simple uh
tweak can easily help other machine
learning teams across different
companies as well to scale down on
costs and
and influence time for their various
tasks so
that's simply what i was looking to talk
about uh then references to the paper
and then the blog post if anyone is
interested in kind of thoughts in their
teams
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much right um gloria
lovely if you'd like to get yourself
plugged in gloria we're talking about
data umbrella open source diversity
lovely stuffs
there we are perfect
great big round of applause
so thank you everyone for being here i
will try to honor your time with a good
talk let's see how this works out so um
i would like to present two topics i'm
very passionate about one is open source
and this amazing group of people who
donate
their time to making our lives so much
much better and then inclusiveness in
tech right
um so um
i would like to make that kind of my
story and how i started contributing to
open source right and this is not my
first open source contribution but it's
the most recent one so you see it's kind
of like just 20 days ago
so essentially i was for work looking at
tf idf and i realized that two things
that should be the same kind of were not
matching up right so then i opened i
mean i went on stack overflow i could
not find an answer i opened an issue on
the cycle
repository and one of the core
contributors answer and say you know
actually this is probably something we
should have
documented better right why don't you
kind of fix that and open a pull request
right so the first time that somebody
kind of said that to me kaf that that
was my reaction
because i you know you have to fork the
repo you have to install from stores you
have to make sure that like the merch
test pass and then you can so i was like
of course i would like to help but
how right
um
so here is a bit where i see data
umbrella coming in right so um what is
data umbrella so it's a community simply
a community for underrepresented persons
in data science it's a non-profit
organization i think it has a great team
i'm not part of that core team but i'm
very passionate about the work they do
and that's why i wanted to promote them
in these crowd right so
what kind of stuff do they do so for
instance they promote open source prints
right and i chose this one because as
you see it's coming pre it's coming up
pretty soon
uh there have been i think three talks
in this conference about pi mc
um so they they organize these open
source contribution sprints to actually
lots of the libraries that supported by
the non-focus project right um and i
think that if you have never contributed
to an open source project it's a
fantastic way of getting into it because
they are core developers from the
libraries they chose issues that are
easier to get started with and you have
coaches that help you right and usually
like you do pair programming so they
pair you up with people who might be at
your level or a bit more advanced so i i
think i love it both from like a social
perspective like having fun but also you
do like something useful in like so
if you want to take a picture of that i
think it's it's um it's a very nice
opportunity coming up soon
now they also have more events coming up
soon right so they have this one on
wikipedia serving the pie touch models
and and i think and i put that picture
and
and the first so i i discovered date
umbrella or the first screen i took in
was in the latin one
for the like psychic learning improving
documentation and so and i put a picture
in hospital right because i think that's
that's one of the things i would like to
highlight
about um diversity that sometimes we
think about diversity in some dimensions
that are visible
like for instance race or even when we
think about disability we think about
disability in in ways that's visible
right and what about what i liked about
data umbrella is that they also put a
lot of emphasis on diversity that you
might not see right you might be talking
to a person who has an autoimmune
disease but unless that person tells you
you would never know right
or you might also think in diversity in
terms of countries like how many
ceos do you know that don't come from
like a western european country or don't
come from canada and the us right so i
think this is it's a it's an initiative
that combines two things that i think
are truly beautiful right
um
so what um so here are ways you can stay
up to what they organize
right so uh the message i want to convey
is if you want to get started with open
source i think this group of people is a
fantastic way to do so
and other stuff you can check out is
their youtube channel they have already
done lots of tutorials so you can just
check it out
they have also playlists on things that
are not strictly like data science
library so i found for instance very
good the career advice ones
what else
yeah career advice one you can sign up
for a monthly newsletter
and here you see a bit kind of the
things that so for instance they also
cover ai ethics and burnout
uh i think especially burnout is
it's a very interesting topic that i
i would i i think they do an excellent
work also on that right and
so yeah that's it from my side i just
want to put again
that slide
and if you want to stay in touch with me
i will be two weeks in london and i
would love to have friends to hang out
i'm definitely going to the pride so uh
yeah just talk to me
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much gloria what uh what
a wonderful initiative and thank you for
calling that out
lovely who have i got next right i
apologize to the next speaker because
i'm gonna probably butcher your name uh
zahi
lovely how close was
it's it pretty good oh all right there
we go yay
for me anomaly detection in the wild
right there we go
presumably this is about animals
well no
that's
so first of all the two disclaimers i'm
a bit nervous i don't think i've spoken
to so many people since my bar mitzvah
um
so and another disclaimer is uh
that i really mocked this uh
presentation up like really fast so
pardon if things like seem like
um you know i just threw a bunch of
images and words and uh
messed them up together
um
this is actually the best slide in my
presentation
everything just goes down here from here
so um
first of all
my name is uh it's fleischer i am uh
i'm leading the detection team
at the data science group at anadot
what we are doing at anna dot is
autonomous business monitoring and
anomaly as a service
basically what this means is that
customers send us data points that
measure different aspects of their
system
and
we get this as a time series and we
model it and find anomalies as the data
comes in
we analyze over 100 million metrics so
we need to be really fast when we model
stuff and
really efficient
in all our algorithms
okay so what do we do when we
basically try to
detect anomalies so
um
what we do is uh try to predict a
distribution for the next data point
that we
received from the client and so what we
create is a
is a baseline you can see it here
we have an upper bound and a lower bound
where we allow the matrix
to be
and if it falls below or above then we
we say that we have an anomaly so this
is like the basic thing that we do on
top of it we have other mechanisms which
aggregate anomalies into incidents that
may happen at different
aspects of the of the system
and this whole magic happens
by running an offline process
which selects the best
model for the time series and we have an
online process which updates this model
as more data points
comes in so now i will just uh
run through a
quick
through several um problematic scenarios
that we encounter in our system
in our matrix in our metrics from real
clients so um
one of the things is is gaps we love
those uh
you know uh
the data points that come in from our
clients are sometimes not
regular
we might have gaps in them and this can
really mess up the inner state
of the model
um in a state it's something no kind of
a psychological
you know models have feelings too and
this is really a common problem really
common problem
another
thing that you
want to address when you try to
model uh time series are events
um events can have a repeating pattern
over the behavior of the metric and if
you don't include that
um when you try to predict the next data
point of the time series then for
example these two events would have been
an anomaly and you don't want that
um
another thing that we love are change
points
and
this can be a change in the
you know in the mean of the time series
and what you really want to do here
is uh
first
um
consider that as an anomaly we have
something unexpected happening but you
really want to adapt first to the new uh
state of to the new order of things to
the new normal
um
this is another thing that is related
um
to the changing states sometimes we have
a drift we have a seasonal pattern
this is not take my world through it we
have a seasonal pattern here that drifts
oh wait
this is supposed to be a surprise um
that drifts you can see here if i plot
the uh season p the periodic pattern
overlaid and colored
uh from the earliest time to the most
recent time you can really see that
there is a drift
in the pattern and you really want to
adapt to it as fast as
as possible
um
so this was
really just a quick uh um
you know running through all the uh
problematic some of the problematic
steps that
we at anadot encounter
and um
so so anomaly detection is really uh
full of challenges
and uh
using you know out-of-the-box tools
sometimes you need to tweak them
break you know algorithms and
remove layers add layers
uh to really handle the the actual data
that you get in reality
so here we actually have a an anomalous
penguin
you can try to find that
um like i'll give you
anybody sees it
yeah
yeah
right okay
so that's it how much time do you do
that's it
there we go
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect there we are well organized
lightning talkers right raphael
i have you next talk about khan code and
of course in parentheses i think you put
if you have time
of course we have tommy mate off you go
great
i mean well we've got time you've got
five minutes uh but we certainly do i'll
need to yeah
fighting talk there we go
love yourselves there we are round of
applause
thank you
promise i won't talk about condos this
time um so i just wanted to quickly take
the time to it's i'm not affiliated to
this website i'm just a user it's really
great resource to go kind of once you're
you pass the beginners phase in python
and
they buy data tools and you want to
learn how to kind of become intermediate
and an expert i really love this website
which covers kind of loads of libraries
that were presented today and loads of
others too so as you see here they have
at the
today 86 courses uh there's also the
newsletter you can subscribe to and
every time there's new courses they they
update it and yeah they have it
over
[Music]
loads of different subjects some
python toolings
and also
some
like
how to build a package how to test
documentation but also some data tools
like visualizations or
libraries like dirty cats and it's
really
well done
there's short videos you can go through
and then there's always some code you
can copy
uh and use and uh yeah it's just
a short yeah that's all i have to say
short recommendation it's really a great
resource and
you should check it out
that's it
[Applause]
our sneaking suspicion khan code is the
brainchild of vincent varbadama he does
the amsterdam
there we go right antonio
you're next now of course antonio i'm
going to read this out as intended
because you've done it in all caps
so
are all data scientists going to lose
their jobs due to ridiculously large
pre-trained models like gpt-3
so clearly you're looking to start a
fight
it's against the code of conduct and i
cannot possibly sanction the talk but
you will have five minutes because
well yeah
you ready yeah brilliant big round of
applause
uh yes i want to talk about uh gpg3 and
gpt3 is ridiculous and the question is
are we all going to lose our jobs
because gp3 for those who don't know i
have a little glossary gp3 is a
massively large model released in 2020
by a company called openai to generate
human-like text but it also solves a lot
of nlp problems like you know without
very little training and open ai despite
its name did not release the model
opening so you have to pay to use if you
go there and the second part of the
glossary if you're not from the uk the
word ridiculous might mean good or bad
which is
which is an ambiguity that i cannot
understand
so yeah what what you know what what can
you do with the gpg3 you can impose that
open ai and then you can say you know
this is a token and you can ask it to
complete a text you say you know rose is
a red violet's ah and it's going to say
blue and it's going to tell you a very
nice you know second line as well
but what is cool about that is that you
can do something called zero shot
learning you can ask it to tr to train
with our training data so you can say
get a
you know a conference uh abstract and
give me tags for that and the tags are
actually really scarily good and and
you know let's try in another talk
nice talk nice tutorial about desk and
even put some hashtags which i don't
know why but you know it's really good
tags
and this is called zero shot learning so
you're not training you don't have any
training data but you're actually
performing a task which is text
classification and you can do few shots
if you show it two or three examples it
will usually learn the task very very
quickly
you can even ask for a you know a tag
for this talk that i'm giving to be very
meta
and it gives a very you know very good
task and
even more scarily you can write a doc
string and you can say can you build a
keras model to classify texts within 10
groups and i have a thousand data points
and it builds and it runs
this is crazy right
but the idea for this talk came when a
colleague of mine who gave a talk and
nick is still here oh no i think he left
but have he given he gave a talk uh
sort of like sooner on a multi-label
classification model that we worked on
together and he comes to me and then he
says we spent two years working on those
i got 63
but then yesterday in a couple of hours
you particularly got 61 percent by
showing only five examples to it and
then it got really really scary good um
and then we got a bit depressed and then
the question is are we all going to lose
our jobs because of that you know so
it's so quick and um so we did some back
of the envelope calculations um you kind
of see the back of the envelope is the
one on the left
um
so at the moment those models are really
hard right it takes two minutes per 10
inference and if you calculate about ten
ten dollars
sorry sorry 10p per dog it would take
like 12 grand per 100k docs which is a
task that we run every day so it was
like
and then it would actually take 16 days
so it's quite prohibitively um
really expensive so that's one one thing
well the second thing you might say is
it's just for nlp right but you know
there are researchers doing research and
doing those type of models for tablet
data for image data for the types of
data um and so and actually optimizing
and making it cheaper and cheaper um but
actually the reason why i think this is
not going to take our job so the answer
is no um is because it kind of solves
one very little part of the ecosystem
which is the dot fit right is the only
thing it's doing is it's the the train
function but this is a very tiny part of
what we really do the tiny part of the
square that is the ml code is all the
infrastructure of understanding the
problems evaluating properly and then
you know like you're feeding data into
uh your
your ecosystems and then translating
machine learning metrics to business
metric and etc so i think it's very
exciting that we can iterate fast with
those models you know exciting times to
be alive but as far as losing our jobs
is concerned i think interest rates are
more scary
[Applause]
thank you very much antonio wonderful
stuff right
one you're up next with the uh
impenetrable untitled two it could be
anything
you know i try and screen these things
before they come up just in case there's
anything to flag but one has of course
found the loophole in the lightning talk
saga
it is
any audio yes
uh
big round of applause
[Applause]
oh
mm-hmm
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
do
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah so following that
[Music]
[Laughter]
what
dear me
it's about as good as it gets
uh adam
uh python squared in a multi-page app
the only thing i'm gonna take away from
that is that there was no talking so
that doesn't count as a lightning deal
[Laughter]
yeah that's quite right although it
could be just an expression of sound
escaping the body i mean it's
love yourselves
have five minutes okay no more dubstep
we've had enough dubstep i promise there
will be zero dubstep
big big round of applause for adam
yeah this is now a good last talk um
[Music]
so anybody who's met me before knows
that i'd like to pitch into lightning
talks and i like to live dangerously so
i've decided to do something i've never
done before which is i'm giving a
presentation in a live coded app
so if this breaks it is all my fault um
we've learned a lot over the last few
days and there's tools have been flying
around some might be new to people but
there's always something new to add to
them and i've been experimenting and
playing a little bit with some of the
things that i've been hearing about
certainly over the weekend and i thought
i'd share them so
lots of people have shown in some places
streamlit apps which are great as a
final endpoint easy access point and
something that i know that i've battled
with in the past is trying to put
multiple pages into an app who else has
had that problem
yeah it's now native they fixed that
problem
literally by setting up the structure
like that
of your code i've stolen it from their
web page literally gives me this
multi-page app by structuring the code
putting files in and it will render each
one as you jump to it
now that's all well and good
but this is running on localhost this is
me running it here so
great that i've gone and put web links
on it but how on earth would any of you
have access to it well recently i had
this problem and i discovered through
google
ngrok
so this is just a simple function at the
top which cube's a selected number
but
if anybody who has a laptop or device
open
preferably not using safarix i don't
think it works very well on safari but
it does work in chrome i believe if you
go to that web address you will log into
my app running on my machine right now
now i'll leave it it's just a bit dot l
y slash pi data hyphen ngrok
this is me screenshotting from their web
pages
you just download the binary for your
specific system you can create a free
account free tier there's a little bit
of end grop magic that has to go on
where you get a you copy and con
paste your configuration token and then
you fire it up tell it what port what
product protocol you want to accept and
you get a little terminal piece which
gives you the address which i've hidden
behind bitly at the moment
but
in theory that means that anybody here
can now access and test out my app so if
you're sharing stuff
where you just need somebody a customer
or somebody to have a quick go with
something rather than having to push it
all the way up into a cloud or onto a
full web server you've got an easy way
to test
web application style stuff out so
anybody had a chance to try the link yep
you've got it working great
um you can even change the theme you can
do whatever you want on there at the
moment i will be turning it off at the
end of this talk in case and i'm not
supporting them at the level of i don't
know if there are horrific security
vulnerabilities in here you can password
protect things but go and read the
documentation and look at it for
yourselves the final thing i was really
curious about having seen pi script and
being talking about python in the
browser is could i run python
inside of python so this is
what i have here
this is me doing a very james powell
style thing i think um not quite as good
as james could ever do it but um you
will notice that the streamlet app is
being declared as running on my mac os
and then what i've actually got is i've
embedded inside the streamlit app pi
script and it's running its own check of
what platform it's running and you can
see a different version of python is
actually an operation in that one cell
there so yes you can nest all of this
together in probably horrific ways if
you really really decide you want to
and if anybody's interested in finding
out more about me i'm a data scientist
and recovering astrophysicist and you
can find me on twitter and linked in
there
[Music]
[Applause]
and of course last book by no means
least james powell is doing a you're
doing a follow-up lightning talk i'm
doing follow-up lightning talk and the
talk is called inconsistent but not
incoherent uh so of course if you miss
james wonderful rendition of coherent
but the other way around
yeah there we go there was one yesterday
that he did so here we go there's a two
it's a lightning talk in two parts love
it what what more could you ask for
let's see if we can get this up on the
screen kind of feels like it's cheap
taking ten minutes but oh there we go
well you know what i figured that next
year more of you need to sign up for
lightning talks and to really motivate
you i'll motivate you with this threat
watch my lighting
there you go with threats
[Applause]
so after i gave the lightning talk
yesterday called consistent but not
coherent or sorry coherent but not
consistent about pandas and some
problems with the pandas api i texted
the panda's lead developer and i told
him about the talk and he was very upset
that he didn't have an opportunity to
see himself and so i told him don't
worry i wasn't trying to put down the
project i was trying to show something
about the project itself i want to show
you the other side of it this is
inconsistent but not incoherent we're at
pi data london it's sunday
june 19th 2022 my name is jamespal you
can follow me on twitter if you like
this bear in mind do not take this talk
seriously this is genuinely how i use
pandas i say from panda's import data
frame i clearly do not know what i'm
doing now it is very much the case that
oftentimes when you're doing a corporate
training you're showing somebody how to
use pandas you start with something very
simple like a date time you know some
date value some entity values and you
create a data frame and you show them a
computation so for example if i'm trying
to model some sample prices or something
i might say that we can take a normal
distribution for the prices themselves
and we might say that we have one of
these for each individual entity and
this gives us the starting prices then
we can add to this thing
a normal some kind of random walk
starting from say
you know some percentage move basically
one percent and because we know how
index alignment works we know that this
k or sorry how we know how broadcasting
works we know that we want to make it
structured like this and because we know
that we want this to be some movement we
can do a cumulative product here and
then we should be able to do a ravel
here because pandas expects this to be a
one-dimensional structure and if we get
all of our parentheses in place which is
always a little bit tricky we should be
able to get a little bit of data now we
just need to fix one small thing here
like that and we have a little bit of
data and this represents some sort of
time series on some sort of entity so
we'll add the index in there and then
somebody says that we want to do some
sort of computation of course we have to
create the index and so here this will
be a multi-index
created from the product of
the dates and the entities of course
we'll have to name these things in a
moment
so here we have the dates
and the entities
and we'll have to name this on the date
and the entity and for the most part
this kind of live coding is kind of
gimmicky i mean you know you can do it
very quickly you can show off what
you're doing and you kind of show off
that look i can
write a bunch of code all at once to
represent some sort of data and of
course you can see some of the instances
of the pandas api namely that should be
named not names but then you can do some
sort of operation on this you can say do
a group eye on the entity and then do a
transform on this and one of the things
that we know about how this is going to
work is if we want to do some sort of
rolling mean on this we'll have to do a
reset index on the entity and we'll have
to drop that otherwise it's going to
give us a really nasty error and then
we'll do a rolling and then we'll roll
this over two days and then we'll do a
mean and we get some sort of operation
here and you look at this and you say
how on earth can you do that off the top
of his head is he just trying to show
off and the answer is yes i'm just
trying to show off however pandas is
actually fairly coherent there is a core
conceptual idea this is what you're
doing when you're using pandas you have
gone out into the field and you've
collected some measurement that
measurement is a scalar measurement so
there's one singular scalar value for
each individual measurement you have
decided that you want to use you want to
encode certain things like missing data
so you use a pandas array instead of a
numpy in the array which allows you to
represent missing integer data with the
capital i int 64 data type which is
confusingly named because what's
interesting capital i int and lower case
i in well one of them has the ability to
have an out-of-band encoding of this
missing data but you say to yourself
it's not enough to just capture the data
i need to capture data along with some
metadata i need to put labels on each
one of these data points for example
time series labels so i've collected
some one-dimensional data and i've
labeled this one isn't the zeroth
element the first element the second
element but for day one day two day
three day four
and
if you think about it this is why when
you look at x-ray which is a package for
managing two-dimensional or
three-dimensional or n-dimensional data
and you look at the coordinate system on
it it is built out of pandas indices
basically a panda's index is just a way
to refer using some human structure for
or some human meaning for the individual
elements it's not element or not
measurement one two and three it's
measurement captured at one inches past
a center point two inches past the
center point so this is why xray looks
the way it is and this is why xray uses
pandas under the covers but when you are
using pandas you're often using
something like a data frame what is a
data frame a data frame is when you take
two one dim or more one-dimensional data
sets and you combine them and you align
them a panda's data frame is not a
two-dimensional structure it is like
indexed one-dimensional data
fundamentally the underlying data is one
dimensional you're just taking multiple
collections of data and you're aligning
them
and as a consequence what you can think
is there's a core idea here pandas is
all about index aligned data
and so when you want to understand how
patnas works you want to understand it
in terms of indexes and index alignments
and you already do this in the course of
your regular work when you use numpy you
think about operations between numpy and
d-rays in terms of a very simple set of
rules namely the rules of broadcasting
so for example when you look at this
code with a two by three by four
structure and a two by three structure
you know it's not going to work to add
these together because this doesn't
broadcast because you know when you
broadcast you write a line and then you
match from right to left and so this
won't work instead you need something
like a two by three by four structure
with a three by four structure that
works or with the original structure you
need to do something like a new axis to
create a synthetic axis so it right
aligns properly so we know when we're
using numpy if we have two numpy
structures in order to make them
interoperate we need to follow some
rules and those rules are broadcasting
in fact even if we're a pure python
programmer we've seen these things like
this before because if we use
collections.counter when you have two
collections.counter and you do an
arithmetic operation on them there's
rules it matches up the keys for these
in fact a surprising thing is the
collections.counter is a first order
approximation to a pandas series and so
you can see when i take these two
collections and i add them together it
matches up the a's against the a's the
b's against the b's the c's against the
c's the these against the these that is
basically the idea of index alignment
because when you have two pandas series
and you add them together it matches
them along the index the index is
metadata indicating what this
measurement means and so when you do
operations you say oh this measurement
at one inch past the center point this
measurement one inch passes number one
use those match those up and in fact the
rules of index alignment are fairly
straightforward you can see here one of
the rules of index alignment is it nand
fills unless you use the dot add method
but that's still not particularly good
because you can see that it goes through
float but when you do series against
series it index aligns on the index
that's the rule of index alignment for
series when you have operations data
frame against data frame it index the
lines on both the columns and the
index when you have operations data
frame against series that gets a little
bit harder it index aligns the index of
the series against the columns of the
data frame and so that's always a little
bit confusing for people why it is that
when i have a data frame i get all these
nands all over the place well you look
at the index of the series and the
columns the data frame that's how it
matches them up and it matches them up
and then a nand fills when it can't find
anything and there's a couple of
slightly more complex rules one of those
slightly more complex rules is if you
happen to have two structures which have
indices and they are neither monotonic
nor unique then it will do a cartesian
product and so here if i do an index
aligned operation and these are neither
unique nor monotonic it'll actually do a
cartesian product because i can't figure
out how to match them up it says i have
two c's here and two c's here and
they're not lined up exactly because
these are not sorted so i'm just going
to figure out every c against every c
and that's why you get six elements here
this is how pandas works and pretty much
every part of the api is orientated
around this idea of index alignment
there's really not much more to it
there's a lot of inconsistencies in the
api but when you think about how pandas
works and you're perplexed why is it the
case that there's group i apply group by
transform and group by ag and really
think about it do you know when you use
these or do you choose apply first then
add next then transform none of them
work and then you go back around and try
apply again oh yeah it worked this time
but why didn't it work the first time
well it's because you're not thinking in
terms of the index because when you
think of something like group by ag
that's about re-indexing the structure
on the thing that you're grouping by you
can see the index changed you're
re-indexing the structure and creating
one element per element in the grouping
when you do a group by transform it's
about preserving the original indexing
that's why you can see the original
indexing of this structure and the new
indexing is the same and when you do a
group by apply there are no rules
associated with which is why when you
grow up a group i apply you get an extra
layer on that index because otherwise
you wouldn't be able to identify which
of these calculations resulted from
which of the grouping operations
all of pandas actually make sense it is
a quite coherently designed api it's
just remarkably inconsistent in terms of
small little details and so
when you go back to work and you use
pandas here's what i want you to do
complain on stack overflow complain on
github you're going to do that anyway
but in the back your mind think a little
bit about index thank you so much
[Music]
thank you james full of useful
information of course two minutes over
but it shows you that of course if
you're one of the organizing people
within nun focus you get special
privileges
right
so i'm not going to keep you much longer
than we are billed as
you in a sunday and it is time to go
home i am going to quickly go through
some closing notes which is largely just
to say thank you to all the people that
make this thing happen so of course
thank you to our sponsors in particular
thank you to optiva tesco and anaconda
as oh hello there we go as our as our
diamond level sponsors and of course man
hl um who they sponsor the conference
and they sponsor us for every single
meet-up that we have done for the past
six or seven years uh so they are deep
they're in deep with a sponsorship with
us thank you ever so much for all of our
sponsors here uh for making this event
such a useful commercial success um
thank you to our keynoters for giving up
their time that's silvan tanya and susan
fantastic contributions to our schedule
today thank you to all of the speakers
it takes an enormous amount of effort to
put together a good talk and we had so
many excellent talks today i think
you'll agree and of course all the ones
you are unable to get to because of
scheduling conflicts they will be online
as soon as we physically can get them
online and i'm sure you'll enjoy them
there
um thank you very much to num focus for
giving us this kind of funkrum with
which we can lift up all this core
development there we go stretching my
metaphors um
it's and thank you for all the badges as
well it is keen to point out that this
is now their 10-year anniversary of
having been advocates of the core
libraries inside of python in particular
director leah silen who's is she still
here leah
no so leah of course has been here for
10 years so it's her 10-year anniversary
we all said thank you very much to her
on a previous day if she's not here
that's absolutely fine but there we go
thank you love focus if you are
extremely keen to do more for non-focus
you can donate uh it is the biggest
source of funding for num focus these
events actually are a uh do three things
they help raise money planet in london
is a profitable event in the sense that
all the money goes to another focus um
it helps us to educate the community and
provide that uh place where we can
include people uh
for that
for the purposes of diversity uh so of
course there is that qr code there
do you feel free to make donations to
them um thank you to our volunteers
thank you to all of them earlier these
people who've sacrificed their entire
weekend to be here with you
a lot of them had not done this before
so you've got that added bonus that they
are probably a bit scared of being
thrown in a room and run a room but they
do it perfectly thank you ever so much
for making this thing flow thank you
very much to our child care i don't know
how many people did anyone here use the
child care they've probably taken the
kids home by now uh no there we go so as
part of making the conference super
inclusive we've had child care for the
past three years
what we try and do is uh shout this out
as much as possible because conferences
having child care is sadly and
shamefully uh not a common thing it is
remarkably easy to set up and we are
very grateful to care relief who are
really straightforward to hire in to to
do that so if you are hosting a
conference you want to provide child
care do talks about that thank you very
much to our av team if you want to stand
up away there we go
i'm i'm pretty sure i didn't hear any
feedback at all the entire thing so
that's fantastic well done thank you
thank you very much to our tower hotel
staff they have been waiting on you they
have been uh bringing things they've
been taking things away that is
fantastic thank you ever so much uh for
your consistent work here of course one
apology to our vegan and our vegetarian
attendees i'm very sorry that we had a
bit of a muck-up on the friday saturday
and sunday we're delivering vegan
vegetarian food we have noted this and
we will improve it next time we also
improve the labeling so sorry to those
who have allergies and possibly found it
very stressful and difficult that things
weren't properly noted on those we are
aware of that and we will fix it for
next year thank you to our wonderful
photographer this is partly how we pay
[Applause]
this is partly how we pay our wonderful
speakers is we give them these wonderful
soft focus beautiful shots of them doing
their talks and they put them on their
linkedin profile you'll suddenly see
them all go up it is very much the case
this of course is an in-joke that is of
course bokeh we want to focus on things
in the front fade in the background
there we go i think you'd like that one
good thank you very much to the rest of
my committee here they are again these
are the people who helped organize this
and have been organizing this for a long
time now so thank you very much to all
of them for reviewing talks for getting
t-shirts in
ordering rubber ducks with logos on
getting
logos put together so they'll fit on
mugs and t-shirts and things like that
um yeah it's impossible to do without
people giving up their time to make it
happen
and of course that is the kind of the
tail end of my thank yous
of course this is just the beginning of
your pilot journey if this is the first
time you've been with us we have a meet
up we run every single month and we're
restarting it we had our first one a
month ago it's the first tuesday of
every month so do look at this meetup
page you can find it on meetup.com if
you'd like to speak if you if you
weren't able to get on the conference
series there is always the chance to
speak at the meetup we have about 300
people every month we run our conference
every month and you can come along and
you can and you can talk to your peers
and it's a fantastic way of giving back
to the community and meeting people if
you'd like to submit a talk there's a qr
code there or of course just google for
it for submitted talk it's a little
google form
and of course it's never goodbye it's
very much to see you soon because we
will see you at the next one we will see
you with the meetups we will see you in
your contributions so uh yeah not a
goodbye it's uh i'll feed a scene and
yes safe travels home to all the various
places you've come from and thank you
for making such a wonderful event
[Applause]
you